o pólo sejam bem vindos a mais um vídeo
e hoje vamos ensinar como fazer mas na
época uma do grupo p
no momento eu tenho jogado um pouco o
trai com um amigo meu miguel e ela é
muito bom eu sou mais ou menos
aí eu pensei bem e vamos fazer esse
projeto em conjunto eo ficar atrás da
câmara a filmar e que dar as dicas e ele
vai ficar aqui fazer o que eu costumo
fazer um aumento que é fazer um projeto
explicar para vocês agora eu não tenho
muita experiência com coisas manuais é o
primeiro fusca álcool foi é montar a
minha vitória aqui no escritório e
parafusos grupo cuf cultura tentou
perceber e vou deixá-lo assim e sempre
que houver caiu posso usar com ele caso
isso para atacar o que achou de entrega
[Música]
o pessoal mano é melhor eu ir longe a
linha do equador
hoje vamos ensinar como fazer móveis na
época
para começar faça o download dos templos
localizados na discrição ao imprimir ser
fixo que a pressão está toda em alta
este projeto é composto por várias
placas
começamos pela placar vamos deixar a
folha de uma intacta seguida por todas
as abas das folhas por trás da pequena
sacola não foi a central
juntamos as coisas todas faça o mesmo
ocorreu com estas placas
agora vamos esclarecer sangue uma placa
catho online 5 mil índios acham que
estes quatro anos quais uma caixa de
cartão disse ele acha que não
agora vamos claro estamos na corda
aplicar a copa uniformemente
parece claro é paga para me inspirar
contra o sol
essa
[Música]
olha a cortar por 10 x ato grande um
bisturi para os pequenos estádios cortes
parte é cinzento escuro sendo os buracos
para os parafusos opcionais pequim nesta
placa e coca cola em todas as partes
brancas seguida coloque esta porta por
cima escura e até que segue agora vamos
colocar um objetivo claro que eu já
inseriu lost
vamos colocar na princípio se deixe
descansar em inglês do primeiro caso
isso não aconteça debaixo do chicote
insira cola então na parte pra cá e
depois pressione
[Música]
isso é parte do sinal porém o documento
uma vez que aumenta bastante o organismo
das nações podem fazer estava toda ou
então só na colônia
populares placas usei como quem for eu
sou bastante rápido com ela mas eu
recomendo que vocês usem uma cola viknan
e sim vocês vão ter mais tempo para
ajustar a placa no sítio certo uma vez
que elas demoram mais tempo para ficar
[Música]
o quarteto usando uma tesoura e de
seguida dobre pela agência3 fechado com
a ajuda de uma régua
[Música]
agora vamos fazer o clube que fica no
centro da óptica
[Música]
penso em tudo pelo centro do cubo
empreendam com cola dos dois lados
depois coloque os cilindros maio cônicos
em cada extremidade do tombo
[Música]
faça um circo com 300 dentro e outro com
dois centros e depois façam círculos
mais pequeninos era ter um centro com a
ajuda do bisturi
[Música]
qual é o círculo site anteriormente na
extremidade da ótica
o resultado final não ficou muito bonito
por isso descobrir as partes usando
pedaços de papel e depois penso lá
usando cola branca
deixei ficar um dia para o outro mansur
duas horas acho que associam o estado em
seco para fazermos o cano eu vou fazer
uma super folha para isso vou usar seis
folhas tamanho a3 por aí vocês não
tiverem folhas a 3 que é basicamente
esse tamanho que podem simplesmente
juntar duas folhas com o tamanho a4 e eu
vou fazer isso uma vez e depois vocês
fazem estas folhas a3 a carne usada uma
cola branca e com o pincel passar e que
na margem
[Música]
agora vou sobre o for mais ou menos como
o centro já está temos que o folha de
tamanho a3 vão precisar fazer seis
folhas como esta aqui é mais uma que
vamos usar para fazer rir mas vocês vão
ver isso aí já tenho aqui a minha super
folha e como podem ver temos que olhar 3
a 3 depois mais de 4 a 3 para a lei e
vou enrolar isto mas não conseguiu lá
muito bem assim e não tenho nada que
sirva de referência pra isso vou fazer
uma rifa e vou colocar aqui ea partir
daí vou enrolar a volta dela e outra
folha a3 e vou começar a arrumar a
partir deste vídeo aqui vou posar
vai tentar assegurar assim e vou colocar
um pouco de fita cola para aprender
futuro
apesar de não tirar esta quarta seja nós
não liberta e não vai ter um lar seguro
envolvem vai ganhar quem já temos aqui
um tubo que vai servir de referência
para outro grande vocalista mas vou
começar a falar com muito cuidado
ok parte mais difícil já está feito
agora é só arrumar até o final da folha
veja o que ela está fazendo assim uma
coisa assim uma economia cada lado então
eu vou empurrar para ficar outro grande
fazedor mas eu já vou fugir no final
para finalizar e colocar cola aqui e
fechar o jogo
já temos aqui o nosso ver que tinha um
retângulo que com mais ou menos cinco
milímetros passagem a espessura desta
peça aqui e vou abrir até chegar à mãe
do tokai e depois vamos colocar esta
peça aparece você tirar vai falar dele
foi empurrar e ver se elas as do outro
lado da namorada depois deixar cada ano
fica mais forte do botafogo só entrar no
prédio
já agora já não atrapalha e de seguida
vou colocar este incidente procurar vou
usar cola quente o bastante
eu vou pular todas as partes vão começar
popular ótica esta parte da arma
[Música]
em seguida vou colocar colar à volta
desta parte da junta aqui extra tango à
volta disto e depois colocar estes
conectores e vou fazer o mesmo para esta
parte aqui defendendo essas partes
ajudou mesmo a aumentar a conexão seja a
força da conexão assim isto vai ficar
lúcido e vou por agora o tubo papel que
eles aprendem a tocar bastante cola
neste canal colocar o tubo que quatro
círculos do lado de quatro do outro lado
que vamos juntar e luz para formar
aquelas coisas que orgulham a ótica mas
já tenho uma parte cinza claro e vou
colocar cola aqui ou maio
depois eu for um cerco vez masculino em
cima da bola
inteiro do percurso igual e para
terminar a estudar se romper com o
destaque do colégio cedup igualmente e
agora tem que fazer o mesmo para esse
lado aqui já foi escolhido também eu vou
colar na ótica agora já não me lembro
sua opinião era em cima outro lado eu
cometer o crime em cima eu estiver
enganado por vocês fazem acontecer
para enfrentar os desafios que vocês
tenham gostado infelizmente o miguel não
conseguiu fazer o vídeo até o fim porque
eu fui promovia gen
mas acho que ele se portou muito bem e
diga o que você deixar nos comentários
porque vai ficar muito feliz veio lemos
é isso muito obrigado até a próxima e
claro não se esqueçam de usar os óculos
de proteção e responsáveis